[Music]
[Applause]
the popular host of the nfl network he's
nominated for
sports emmy big shot
rich eisen of course the rich eisen show
that follows this show
on peacock how did you celebrate when
you when you learned that you were going
to be
up for the studio host sports emmy
yeah what was your reaction well i did
uh
you know i went through the usual ptsd
to see if costas got nominated too
see it's not fair rich because costas
isn't in the
he's not in the category anymore right i
know so
ernie's still there so um i don't know i
i just wanted to know if this meant
uh i i got on a plane to new york or not
just to sit in the back of the room
you know it's it's funny the those
sports emmys uh used to be when you
when you won which year did you you won
you won studio host
what was that um i forget what year it
was but i remember it was a party it was
a bash it was at the old
spot in times square where there were
open bars in every single corner of the
room and it was a great
social gathering for everybody to get
together and see one another yeah
i forget what year it was uh 1997
i think i was there i was there i was
there and it was a blast your speech was
great
and we were all hammered i mean to be
honest with you because
it was a party you know it was an
absolute party for everyone to get
together and
but anyway it's it's an honor to be
nominated there you go there you go
to get around to that one okay who do
you think first
yeah when you win oh my wife
my wife i'll thank my wife first and
then my lord and savior steve bornstein
who was smart enough to have hired me
twice got me started on my career with
nfl network and espn
um and of course everybody who's uh who
helps make it possible
but i don't think i'll get to say those
things dan um that said uh uh
it was it's it's just you know
everything that's gone on in the last
year
for everybody um it's been a remarkable
year for a lot of people
in our industry um certainly last year
when
there was a pandemic and what do we do
and what is our role and what is our
place in the world and
and you know your show being nominated
and
um this show being on the air period
you know is wait are you working on your
speech right now
no i'm just actually going i'm just
talking like what's from
no you're workshopping this a little bit
no no
all right so let me i'd like to thank
dan patrick um
because my wife and my wife and susie
yeah yeah yeah
that's the way it'll work i think that
would be great if if you did that
okay if you win can you promise that
you'll thank me before you thank your
wife
um i won't do that but here's maybe what
should maybe i should do this because
i thought maybe tom brady should do this
when he's in uh
here in los angeles at so far up the
road from here next year when he's
playing the rams
maybe what i should do is what i think
he should do which is
take a tape measure out and measure the
space on my zoom to say
i just want to make sure for the next
years that i've got you know that i'm
i'm i'm all set for doing this you know
like i'm
i plan on winning here a lot you know
what i mean like that's the sort of
thing okay
what do you think should i do that yeah
yeah go get them
go get them i've led you to slaughter
before so you know
don't trust me don't trust me no that
was one of the first things as a
professional broadcaster i learned dan
yes but you were you were so earnest and
i
i led you to slaughter and i i felt bad
i felt bad after the fact that i
embarrassed you in front of susie
colbert
we're really going there do you what
should i tell the story dan now that you
just walked me into it or is that what
you're saying i mean was it
at a party and i was talking to her i
had just arrived at espn
and i said to her where are you from and
you
was it a backyard who's your house what
was it her house and we're going away
parties
laurie zalbowicz's house wow
good memory so i think that was the one
person kenny didn't
mention in his la times article so you
know we're in the backyard
we're in the backyard and um i say to
susie calver
hey you know uh where are you from and
you're 20
yards away and you're oh i'm from ohio
and like the needle ripped off the
record
and uh you're like oh uh you weren't
talking to me huh oh no go back to what
you're doing and it was just
that was the end of the conversation i
know um and then so
yeah we go way back dan yeah yeah we do
uh so kenny mayne kind of gets this
farewell show did you get a farewell
show
at the mother ship um in a cardboard box
with all my belongings oh that's right
you they asked did they escort you out
of the building no it was actually i got
uh
a fax three days before the end of my
contract saying it was over
um and then i showed up the next day
to see what was going on and it was like
yeah that's that's it
no one escorted me to the door but i did
not have a farewell
um you know show yeah kenny gets a
he gets his own show on monday night the
person who was in charge
at the time when i got the gate dan or
when we decided to part ways
um isn't there anymore i've got a great
relationship with everybody
at the worldwide leader as i think you
know you do um
but i i told you this dan like seeing
you
with ko on the set of sportscenter
um a couple of years ago was that i
think it was
yeah and you know it was great to see
the two of you because it was
you know classic all-time great
television when the two of you did
sportscenter together
and it was what made the place how the
greatness
spot that it was in part with some other
great combinations that i was fortunate
enough to
arrive um in 1996 and then get hooked up
with stuart
it was really tough for me to watch
though i had to turn it off
because i'll be honest like i i know i
didn't
i'm not going to get a chance to have
that type of show with stewart anymore
and it really hit me hard because i do
love the times that i was there
and um so yeah you know i i it
it it didn't end well in in 2003 but
everything has gone on
very well since then and my relationship
with with the worldwide leader
with everybody there is is great so a
couple of topics here don't get too deep
and sentimental
i'm sorry i'm sorry okay you're better
than that rich eisen nfl network host
god i just spit take dan yeah i know my
bad okay
rich eisenhower peacock that follows
this uh what's bigger the story
about aaron rodgers or the aaron rodgers
story
like those covering aaron rodgers or the
actual story itself oh god the actual
story itself
i i i mean seriously this is this is
huge dan and if he stays though
right then then it's not a big story
no it it absolutely is because it
depends on on the manner
in which he stays does he get that
long-term contract
numbers on the table that means jordan
love
isn't there anymore and what does happen
to jordan love and what does happen
with the packers because boy the
pressure would absolutely be on to
do what brady did which is go to
multiple super bowls after dispatching
with the jimmy garoppolo conundrum
so we there would be tons of pressure on
all of that
and you know uh the best part about it
is the nfl schedule makers pushed all in
with their chips
they didn't do a darn thing to the first
four weeks that they weren't planning on
doing without
you know with aaron rodgers expecting
him to be there there's four nationally
televised games right up front
so we'll have a front row seat to the
whole thing and then i really think as
you were on the show the other day you
know june 1
was uh is the day where we think this is
all going to go down
you know this is going to actually
either happen or not
because that's when the salary cap
ramifications of being traded
would be lessened so i i love the fact
that what is going on we still don't
know what is going on is it
is it brian gouda kun saying i'm really
really sorry
uh is it uh actually giving him the
terms and dollars on the table what
what does fix this i'm fascinated by it
and you have aaron rodgers going on
kenny mayne's show on monday at least
reportedly yeah okay but i could i mean
that's a big send-off
for for kenneth of maine now those guys
have a good relationship
now does kenny ask questions
leaving the building how does he not
i mean i i i don't know i i mean
aaron's sitting aaron's sitting down if
if he does do that he's sitting down
fully knowing that he's doing his friend
a solid by giving him
the scoop of the summer out the door
which is what
a good friend does for another good
friend as well
and you know he might have a an answer
already ready or a pat answer
that would put kenny in the position of
having to follow up
uh on a friend who's doing him a big
favor a huge solid to to send him out
the door like that
you know but so i i will be tuned in
that's for sure because i i really want
to know
um whether he's going to downplay it or
take the lid off the pot here
one of the two leaving the building
kenny is
the question is is aaron rodgers leaving
the building
the packers i really don't think so the
best place for him to stay
best place for him to win right now is
is where he's staying you know i mean
the broncos i don't think afford him the
ability to win in 2021 like the packers
would
and you could even make the case 2022 as
well because they did sign aaron jones
through the next two years contractually
where
they can actually afford it they did put
aaron jones on the credit card a little
bit here and they've done that with a
couple of their signings not their
center
which might have really pissed aaron
rodgers off as well but i i really think
the
you know it makes sense for all parties
to figure this thing out
and let him actually surpass farv and
star
in times in in years served in green bay
and see if he can actually
match um farv and star in super bowl
appearances
the uh urban meyer portion of the tim
tebow story is what's fascinating
not necessarily tebow it's urban meyer
and how this plays can he possibly
cut tim tebow like you don't bring him
in
it's it's weird i was always told don't
hire somebody that you can't fire
can urban meyer hire tim tebow and fire
tim tebow
oh i think so for sure i mean the whole
point is that
you know he can fire tim he can
basically say we gave you a shot
it didn't work out and look at the rest
of the locker room and say i told you
the best 53 are going to be here
you know i mean like that that actually
would would benefit urban
in the same way that it would benefit
him to actually give tim tebow a shot
and and show everyone that he is
all about um having a culture change in
there and and letting somebody be the
standard bearer for that in the in the
locker room
um i i i'm i the world keeps spinning
you know and
and tim tebow i can't wait to see if he
can make the roster
the first preseason games for
jacksonville will be
something i i i want to watch for for
urban on the sideline and
trevor and under center and shotgun and
and tim doing what he's doing but in the
meantime
if i'm not mistaken shortly before he
came on adam schefter tweeted out the
top five selling items on nflshop.com
are all tim tebow 85s
and that is i bought one yesterday you
know
it's just you know well you want to get
it before he wears 15. yeah you know
like it's
a collector's item yeah more ways than
85 85 you know
so i i i think it's it's something
that's a win for everybody right now the
only person who it's it's hurting is the
one person who could have tried out for
the third tight end spot
uh other than tebow right now that's the
only one and we don't know who that
person obviously would be
so uh hey congratulations again
nominating
sports emmy thanks dp and uh i didn't
mean to get too deep
so uh in that regard um out the door uh
you know my guy mike del tufo is not
here the so-called punk
according to was that you or seton
called him a punk and wanted to throw
down with with
with us i mean yeah is that um
yeah is there something that we could do
we need to address something like uh
like aaron rodgers and the packers or or
what
uh what do you think who are you backing
well i gotta back my well am i doing a
larusso or am i doing an eyesore right
here
i'll do the larussa answer is like look
i know i know
mike sometimes doesn't listen you know i
tell him to do one thing and he does
another thing and i don't want him to
show up the dan patrick show
so you'd please take a swing at him you
know that's one way to do it okay
or the other way is basically like you
know what we have a system here and
we're going to keep it in-house and
you know if you throw behind my guy i'm
going to have to i'm going to have to
take up for him and that's that's my
default i don't have the larussa in me
okay you know uh look i'm going to back
my guy's seating
so okay if uh maybe we cross paths at
the super bowl
okay right here in los angeles
yeah i don't know if seton wants any of
that smoke okay you know
i just don't know if he wants any of
that smoke well we're gonna do like a
do we do like a jake paul um situation
here
where you have floyd where i'd like to
steal the hat and it looks like
something that they've done
is that we need to work on our on our
hype basically right now okay
this could be on the undercard it could
be
season you're fine you want a piece of
uh
rich's yeah rich is one of his producers
i will take
all of said smoke all smoke referred to
i would accept that all right super bowl
super bowl meet friday yeah that's what
we will do let's set it let's set it up
for super bowl meet friday for all the
smoke
guy is the meat
there's not many producers i can say
i've seen that guy with his pants off
okay and i've seen your producer with
his pants off
see i knew we would drill down to the
the
the actual real nuts and bolts of the oh
whoa
oh okay okay symbols all right i gotta
meet friday i gotta go
thanks thank you buddy that's rich eisen
nfl network host rich eisen show on
peacock right after this one
we will uh see what's coming off the
grill next here on the dan patrick show